herr leibe gestern haben wir sie gesehen
vor den kameras sie waren tief berührt
sie konnten die tränen nicht
zurückhalten uns hat das sehr berührt
diese menschlichkeit und auch die trauer
die sie da zum ausdruck gebracht haben
und wären das mit nach hause genommen
diesen tag gestern und wir sind sicher
ihnen ging es nicht anders wie war für
sie gestern der abend haben sie mit
ihrer frau gesprochen haben sie
überhaupt ein auge zugemacht was haben
sie getan als sie dann zu hause ankamen
ich habe mich gestern abend ich war kurz
vor mitternacht zu hause auf das
gespräch mit meiner frau gefreut und mit
ihr die dinge einfach besprechen zu
können und ich finde ehepartner sind in
so einer situation einfach ganz ganz
wichtig man kann sich öffnen man kann
über das erlebte sprechen aber
gleichzeitig war mir natürlich auch
wichtig hier war noch menschen die meine
frau und ich kannten die ermordet worden
sind über diese menschen zu sprechen und
welch schöne erlebnisse wir verbinden
mit diesen menschen
es sind bilder die einem im kopf bleiben
selbst uns die wir von berlin aus dass
gestern verfolgt haben intensiv verfolgt
haben was sind die bilder aber die ihnen
im kopf bleiben von ihrem besuch vor
allen dingen dort am tatort was sind die
bilder die möglicherweise auch im kopf
bleiben
es sind zwei bilder zu beginn dieser
horror fahrtstrecke das ist die
brotstraße da lagen links und rechts
schwerst verletzte menschen es sah aus
wie nach dem krieg oder zumindest stelle
ich mir das so vor
das war die eine geschichte die andere
geschichte ist menschen die vor fünf
minuten nach dem auto ausgewichen sind
weggesprungen sind um nicht getötet zu
werden haben sich um die verletzten und
die um die traumatisierten gekümmert bis
der rettungsdienst da war das sind die
bilder die ich mitnehme
das zweite bild ist da wurde eine frau
tödlich verletzt 25 jahre alt und da
liegt ein turnschuh neben ihr und ich
gucke mir diesen turnschuhe an und mein
impuls ist als mensch als vater
dieses mädchen braucht den zweiten schuh
ich weiß dass das irrational ist in so
einer situation aber so reagieren wir
als menschen und das will ich auch gar
nicht verleugnen haben sie ihre tochter
dann gestern angerufen dieser wachsen
mittlerweile hatten sie mit ihr kontakt
nach diesen erlebnissen
sie sagten gerade auch sie als vater und
auch mich als mutter und das ist fällt
wirklich sehr schwer darüber zu sprechen
das jüngste opfer neun wochen alt da
zerreißt es einem das herz was geht
ihnen durchs herz wenn sie daran denken
ich habe gestern einen unserer
erfahrensten rettungsärzte erlebt wir
versucht hat dieses baby zu retten und
obwohl dieser art zu erfahren ist auch
jemand ist der viel erlebt hat
er hatte tränen in den augen und das ist
wichtig dass in dieser ganzen
professionalität wir uns auch gefühle
leisten und auch zeigen
da ist eine familie mehr als
auseinandergerissen worden was können
sie dieser familie wo der säugling
gestern ermordet wurde was können sie
diesen rest der familie anbieten was
können sie für diese familie ton als
oberbürgermeister
kann dieser familie erzählen wir heute
tausende vor der porta nigra waren und
solidarität bekundet haben ich kann
dieser familie berichten dass es
hilfsangebote ohne ende gibt um den
menschen zu zeigen wir sind für euch da
dass die solidarität in dieser stadt
trägt was ich nicht leisten kann ist
diesen riesigen verlust
schön zu reden diesen riesigen verlust
versuchen zu erklären und deshalb ist
mir ja so wichtig wir hatten gestern 450
polizeibeamten in der innenstadt die
strecke ist ja über einen kilometer lang
die beweissicherung gemacht haben das
können wir als rechtsstaat leisten über
die beweissicherung antworten zu geben
zu versuchen antworten zu geben
herr leider der täter ein 51 jahre alter
mann der in trier geboren ist er im
umkreis lebte wir sprachen jetzt viel
über die trauer was empfinden sie diesen
mann gegenüber da muss ja auch
unglaublich viel zorn und
verständnislosigkeit über diese
unfassbare sinnlose tat mit sein wie
unzufrieden muss man mit seinem leben
sein um wirklich mit der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt hat seit mit
heimtückischer absicht in die innenstadt
zu fahren und menschen zu töten was ist
mit diesem menschen passiert und es geht
auch gar nicht darum im augenblick zu
sagen wie schrecklich der ist ich will
aber antworten wir in trier wollen
antworten was ist da passiert warum hat
dieser mensch keine hilfe warum hat man
nicht früher gemerkt dass dieser mensch
so ein ein werkzeug ist
sie suchen antworten bezüglich seines
motivs wie man das polizeilich nennt
aber auch darum irgendwie zu ergründen
ob man diese tat hätte verhindern können
möglicherweise ist das eine frage die
sie beschäftigt ja natürlich ich mein so
ein täter wir sehen diese bilder sie
sind profis sie sehen diese bilder immer
wieder in der ganzen welt passiert ist
und wir denken immer noch dass es eben
anderswo ausschließlich passiert und
nicht bei uns und dieses grundvertrauen
was wir als menschen ja auch brauchen
dieses grundvertrauen ist in dieser
stadt jetzt erst mal zerstört wir hatten
ja gehört dass der täter ärztlich
untersucht wurde das nicht
auszuschließen ist das ein durchaus
schwieriger psychologischer hintergrund
bei ihm besteht wie gehen sie
damit um glauben sie man hätte das
irgendwie verhindern können wie geht es
in diese richtung jetzt weiter es sind
die profis am werk polizei
staatsanwaltschaft fachleute die
begutachtung machen da halte ich mich
als oberbürgermeister wirklich zurück
hier sind die profis erstmal gefordert
aber es gibt dann zu einem gewissen
zeitpunkt auch darüber und es war ja
auch ihre frage den angehörigen den
menschen den trier antworten zu geben
und deshalb unser rechtsstaat
funktioniert und wir wollen im moment
abwarten aber irgendwann brauchen wir
antworten die fußgängerzone von triers
ab jetzt ein tatort seit gestern kurz
vor 14 uhr werden sie jemals wieder
durch diese fußgängerzone gehen können
und freudig bummeln können shoppen gehen
können
heute noch nicht aber es ist zwar ein
tatort ist es aber auch ein ort der
solidarität die menschen die
trainerinnen und trainer wir haben
normalerweise fast fünf millionen
touristen kroner bedingt waren eben
trier in trier unterwegs die haben
geholfen die haben an diesem tatort
menschen geholfen haben leben gerettet
deshalb ist es tatort aber gleichzeitig
auch ein symbol wie menschen auch wieder
menschen sein können
ja wir haben das gestern auch beobachtet
wie sehr die trierer in diesen schweren
stunden zusammenhalten wie sehr sie
sofort den opfern geholfen haben auch
sie es oberbürgermeister sie waren
sofort zur stelle waren ja wenige
minuten nachdem das ganze passiert ist
auch in der fußgängerzone uns lässt hier
auch besonders das schicksal dieser
familie
das jüngste opfer des lässt uns hier
nicht los das schmerzt einfach zutiefst
haben sie jetzt derzeit kontakt zu
dieser familie sie sagten ja dass sie
viele der opfer auch canon trier ist
eine kleine stadt man kennt sich
nein es geht darum dass die familie
jetzt ein schutzraum braucht und es geht
nicht darum dass der oberbürgermeister
sich aufdrängt gegeben dieser familie
schutzraum das gestalten wir zusammen
mit den profis mit dem psychologen und
dann kommt irgendwann der richtige
zeitpunkt um das gespräch zu suchen aber
nicht zu diesem zeitpunkt vielen dank
für dieses gespräch für diese worte
erlebe in diesem unglück in diesem
schwer begreiflichen oder
unbegreiflichen unglück diesem ort der
der gestern in trier passiert ist sind
sie für mich persönlich ein held in dem
moment weil sie die worte so sehr wählen
und so gut treffen und weil sie die
trierer und alle die es gestern so
bewegt hat so sehr mit nehmen danke
ihnen dafür dankeschön dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren